so now that we're all set up with our
play games libraries we want to start
adding some achievements to our game and
the first thing I'm actually going to do
is add in our built-in controller to
view those achievements so I'm going to
do that by creating a button let's put
on screen here this is good and we will
save you achievements and let's go over
to our sizing we're going to align this
or I guess anchor it to the bottom right
by the way Xcode 5 auto layout is much
better than xcode four if I were to do
this from scratch I'd probably be be
doing that here instead of these springs
and struts anyway we're just going to
call this achievements look leaner and
now I'm going to go into my helper
editor here and i'll set up with an
outlet control drag we'll call it you
achievements button one of these days
I'm going to misspell achievements it's
gonna be really embarrassing and maybe
up here let's add in our achievements
button was pressed action alright with
that setup let's go and edit this thing
first thing we're going to do actually
is within refresh interface based on
sign in i'm going to say self dot view
achievements button dot hidden equals
not signed in
so that we hide this view achievements
button if you're not signed in kind of
make sense the other thing I want to do
here is something that's bugged me since
the last chapter which is in my finish
with auth error handler this refresh
interface based on sign in I want to
move this outside the if not error
Clause because that will want to refresh
the interface either way whether there's
an error or not I mean trying silent
sign and we'll have finished at this
point and maybe we'll just want to show
the button again if things have gone
badly so anyway I was bothering me just
want to get around to fixing it so now
let's get something to happen when the
user presses this view achievements
button we're going to create a gpg
achievement controller equals gpg
achievement controller alloc init we
need to set its achievement delegate to
self at least that's what I'm going to
do here and this achievement delegate by
the way just has one method which is
achievement view controller did finish
it's the method our view controller hair
is going to implement in order to
dismiss this view controller when the
user is all done and then we display it
like we would any other modal view
controller so we're going to call self
present view controller our achievement
controller animated yes and completion
in this case will just be no now of
course we're getting a warning because
we've set our achievement delegate to
self but our self is not yet a gpg
achievement delegate luckily we can fix
that right here and then we get one
other warning that the required method
achievement view controller did finish
has not been implemented I really feel
like there's got to be some key
combination or something here that I can
click for xcode to insert a stub method
for me I've not been able to find it if
it exists and you know about it please
leave it in the comments because I gee
it seems like that'd be awfully nice
however that said it's pretty easy for
us to add so
it does get auto completed for us and uh
basically we're just going to dismiss
view controller animated yes with
completion no and that's it that's all
we need to do right these little lines
of code have done all the work we need
to actually show the achievements view
controller within our game so let's run
this and see what happens alright so I'm
signed in I've got this achievements
button I'm going to click it and I get
this lovely achievements view controller
which is empty and that's because we
haven't defined any achievements for our
game so I suppose this is correct I
click the done button it calls my
delegate method which dismisses that
view controller and there you go we can
now view our achievements within the
game so maybe the next step would
actually be to create some achievements
and we can do that developer console and
so we'll tackle that in the next lesson
the fire
Oh